- To Mrs. Cordell, my
fourth grade teacher.
- To Miss Peterson.
- To Mr. Garbert.
- To Mr. Jones.
- To Miss Wolf.
- To Mrs. Young.
- Mr. Chavez
- Mr. Bhode, fifth and sixth grade.
- To Mr. Blake.
- To Mr. Lester.
- To Mr. Hadwin.
- To Mr. Zarki.
- Doctor Ron
- To Mrs. Alvarado.
- To Gayle Wills and Jenna Susa.
- To Mrs. May Yu.
- To my high school humanities teacher.
- To Mrs. Valentine, my
kindergarten teacher.
(inspiring music)
- Who taught me how to analyze
literature and to write.
- Who first introduce me
to the magic of TV and film production.
- Who helped me find my voice in writing.
- Who encouraged me to
write my first program.
- Who helped me figure
out how to think about
and what I think about
so many different things in the world.
- Who brought so much love
and joy in to the classroom.
- Who demanded excellence
while treating us with respect.
- Who helped me get over
my fear in public speaking.
- Who gave me a book began my
love of science and fiction.
- Who believed in us even
when we blew everything up.
- Who taught me the value
of telling stories to teach
and listening to other people's stories.
- Who is such an amazing woman
I named my daughter after her.
(inspiring music)
- And for making us all
feel special all the time.
- And you were exceedingly
patient with me.
- For helping me discover
my love for writing.
- For pushing me to always be
the best version of myself.
- And for teaching me
that I could accomplish
anything I put my mind to.
- For telling me I was good at math.
- For making sure that I knew
I could do accelerated work.
- For encouraging my love
of reading and writing.
- For making me feel
welcome in our classroom
as a recent immigrant to United States.
- For inspiring me to become
a kindergarten teacher intern
who touched so many lives
both your students
and your student's students
more than you'll ever know.
(inspiring music)
- Thanks, Mrs. May Yu.
- Thank you, Mr. Blake.
- Thank you, Mr. Chaves.
- Thank you, Mr. Garbert.
- Thank you, Mrs. Cordell.
- Thank you, Mrs. Crame.
- Thank you, Mr. Lester.
- Thank you, Mr. Hadwin.
- You've made a huge impact
on my life and so many others.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
(inspiring music)